[Música]
se creen que este esto que observar aquí
qué pensarían si les digo que a partir
de esto podemos crear
sillas o podríamos hacer lámparas
también que ellos tienen la capacidad de
degradar el plástico el petróleo otros
contaminantes de aquí podemos extraer
sustancias antibióticas vitaminas e
inclusive producir biocombustible pero
para la mayoría de ustedes esto que ven
aquí representa suciedad y lo asocian
con enfermedades estos son hongos y son
hongos que capturamos en el ambiente
pueden estar en este momento en sus
manos en la silla donde están sentados
en el aire que estamos respirando
como científica veo los hongos como
organismos a identificar de hecho diez
años de mi vida me la he pasado
investigando una enfermedad de la papa y
el tomate
y no me he cuestionado si este
microorganismo puede tener algún uso
benéfico porque porque como científica
normalmente no me cuestioné ese tipo de
cosas sin embargo aquí traigo otro
ejemplo de otra enfermedad de plantas en
este caso este se llama carbon le afecta
al maíz aquí en colombia quemamos los
cultivos con carbón en mexico los venden
se llama huitlacoche y preparan unos
platos exquisitos con el huitlacoche
porque quiero decir esto porque lo que
para algunos es un problema para otros
fue una oportunidad de negocio y esa es
la importancia de la colaboración la
interdisciplinariedad cuando nos
juntamos con personas que piensan
diferente pueden ver ciertas situaciones
desde una perspectiva distinta
un curso el cual llame hongos mágicos y
perversos a través de este curso ya no
veo los microorganismos
particularmente los hongos como
organismos a identificar los feos como
parte de mi equipo de trabajo estos son
dos producen los hongos perdón producen
los pigmentos con los que bien
estudiantes pueden hacer este tipo de
estampación o estampado en textiles
también con hongos como ven aquí atrás
esto para que conociera un poco cómo es
el cultivo de dónde vienen los hongos
que comemos lo que nos comemos es esa
parte pero detrás de eso hay residuos o
desechos vegetales y crece una masa
fúngica o de hongo que si lo horneamos
en diferentes moldes podemos crear cosas
como estas empaques quien ha pedido algo
por internet llega una caja gigante
cuando uno pidió esto lleno de icopor
nos demoramos cinco minutos en abrir esa
caja y se demoran cientos de años en
degradar el icopor o el polipropileno
extendido dentro de esas cajas
porque no repensar los usos porque no
usar desechos vegetales y hongos por
ejemplo
soy parte del programa de biodiseño y
tengo la fortuna también de dictar un
curso que se llama biodiseño el bio
diseño une mis dos grandes pasiones que
son la docencia y acercar a los
científicos a la ciencia en este curso
de diseño lo dictó conjunto con una
profesora que es diseñadora al principio
dejamos que nuestros estudiantes
exploren dentro del mundo de la ciencia
lo que les llama la atención y los
dejamos trabajar en el área que el más
de la pasión cada clase la profesora de
diseño y yo les damos retroalimentación
cada una desde nuestras perspectivas a
continuación le pueda mostrar cuatro
ejemplos de proyectos que han surgido de
este curso debió dice el primero se
llama root mix root nit parte de la
problemática de que hoy en día no
sabemos cómo cuidar nuestras plantas
cuando la planta será amarilla se de
triste se le acaba una hoja que hacemos
le echamos agua cierto pero las plantas
no solamente necesitan agua la
temperatura es importante la luminosidad
es importante si la tenemos en un lugar
cerrado
hay que limpiarle las hojas porque
empiezan a acumular polvo con el pie lo
que hicieron estos estudiantes fue
utilizar unos sensores que ya están
disponibles que pueden sentar la humedad
del suelo pueden medir la luminosidad
pueden sentar el tacto y conectaron los
sensores a una superficie textil y esa
superficie textil nos comunicaba lo que
le pasaba a la planta si el textil se
arruga la planta le hace falta agua si
el textil se inflaban tenía exceso de
agua si cambiaba de color como amarillo
era porque tenía exceso de luz y si se
ponía blanco le faltaba le faltaba luz
tuvimos la fortuna de presentar este
proyecto en un concurso internacional y
unas personas de google se acercaron al
final y nos dijeron nosotros hemos
tenido esos sensores hace tanto tiempo y
no teníamos ni idea qué hacer con ellos
un segundo ejemplo se llama mein con
mein como parte de la problemática de
desactivar minas antipersonales lo que
hicieron estos tres estudiantes fue
diseñar una bacteria que fuese capaz de
detectar el plástico con el que están
hechas de estas minas antipersonales que
es un material rudimentario una vez lo
detectan las bacterias cambian de color
de esa manera a través de drones uno
podría saber dónde están las minas
antipersonales y evitar que personas o
animales sean los que tengan que ir a
detectarlos además la bacteria tiene la
capacidad de degradar el plástico con el
que está hecho una mina entonces al
exponerla al medio ambiente se va
deteriorando y pierde su actividad algo
que me encantaría resaltar de este
proyecto es que los diseñadores tienen
algo que me fascina que yo no hacía como
científica y es no construye en la parte
de la comunidad o el usuario sino que
van y exploran los contextos y miran si
realmente es una aplicación que use
utilizarían y fueron al ejército pero
tuvieron que decir que eran tres
científicas porque tenían que si decían
eran tres diseñadoras o les iban a abrir
las puertas
el tercer ejemplo se llama judo
siendo parte de la problemática de que
hoy en día estamos mucho más tiempo en
lugares cerrados que en lugares abiertos
en las casas en la oficina en
universidades colegios gimnasios eso
quiere decir que los lugares cerrados
están llenos de co2 y de contaminantes
con todo lo que aplicamos para limpiar y
las cosas que tenemos en la casa
entonces ellos quisieron crear una
superficie una superficie que depende de
la región donde se construye use los
desechos vegetales de esa región en
colombia' utilizarían por ejemplo bagazo
de caña en eeuu podrían utilizar maíz y
en japón por ejemplo podrían utilizar
desechos de arroz a esta superficie
además le ponían un panel con
cianobacterias cianobacterias son
bacterias que tienen la capacidad de
hacer fotosíntesis eso quiere decir que
pueden captar el co2 del ambiente y
liberar
entonces crearon una superficie que se
ve estéticamente bonita que oxigena los
lugares cerrados
el último ejemplo se llama se auto
freeze este ejemplo no partió por una
problemática sino que estos cuatro
estudiantes se apasionaron por un
descubrimiento científico que hicieron
en esa fase de exploración encontraron
que había una bacteria que tenía una
proteína capaz de congelar el agua y ese
era su mecanismo de patogenicidad en las
plantas congela el agua dentro de los
tejidos y rompe los tejidos de la planta
esa proteína hoy en día se utiliza en
los lugares donde se esquía cuando no
hace suficiente frío para hacer nieve
artificial lo que ellos quisieron hacer
fue construir unos módulos para
transportar medicamentos a zonas rurales
sin necesidad de electricidad
los chéveres de este grupo este es un
grupo que vio el curso el semestre
pasado ellos quieren continuar con su
proyecto y lo quieren llevar a cabo
unieron una microbióloga este semestre a
su grupo la microbióloga está en el
laboratorio haciendo los experimentos
pero no los hace aislado de ellos ellos
van al laboratorio toman datos y con
esos datos retroalimenta sus módulos de
hecho ya están cambiando los materiales
porque se dan cuenta que la temperatura
realmente no es la que ellos suponía que
tenían
entonces para terminar les quiero contar
que estos hongos mágicos y a veces
perversos me enseñaron el valor de la
colaboración y la interdisciplinaridad y
con el bio diseño el bio diseño me
demostró que la colaboración entre la
ciencia y el diseño realmente puede
mejorar la calidad de vida de las
personas teniendo en cuenta los recursos
y que garantizando que esos recursos
estén en el planeta por un tiempo más
prolongado gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]